the situation several donetsk is dire
but against the odds ukrainian forces
are fighting back and are gaining some
ground
only a day or so ago russian soldiers
controlled around 80 of the city it's
now closer to 50 50.
the situation in seven of the nets
continues to be very intense there is
uh intense street to street fighting
between the ukrainian army and the army
of these war criminals and aggressors um
they control some part of the city but
during the last couple of days ukrainian
armed forces have been able to carry out
certain
local military operations as a result of
which they were able to
regain some streets regain some parts of
several of the nets
after a month hiding in their basement
vitali and maria made a run for it
they escaped neighboring lucidchansk by
the skin of their teeth
one two three
four four five
five bullet holes in the car
they had moments to decide what to do
and then just go
life in war can change in a moment
your life packed up in the backseat of
the cars
lydia is 74. she lived underground for
40 days as the fighting several donets
went on above her
she now has a six foot by two foot
mattress in a woman's refuge that she
can call her own space
that's about it
m
this is what is happening to even
grandmothers
there is no allowance for age or
innocence
the russian gains in this war might be
small but the human cost is just huge
alastair bunker sky news in eastern
ukraine